Who's the bird headed god of Egypt,
who I told you about,
who represents the
capacity to pay attention.
Very important concept
because the Egyptians realized
and really it's brilliant.
It is something modern people do
not understand cause we tend to make
rationality the highest God that's,
that's not a good thing.
That's a pathway to totalitarianism.
What the Egyptians knew,
but they only knew it in symbolic form
was it was the capacity to attend to
things that in some sense was the highest
psychological function because it's
the capacity to pay attention
that actually moves you
beyond what you only know.
And rationality tends to make,
you know,
integral systems that are coherent,
that are boxlike and then claim
that they're absolutely right.
Whereas the tension is always
looking beyond what you know.
And,
and attention is an
unbelievably powerful force.
You know,
that's why advertisers pay for it.
That's why people demand it.
That's why children can't live without it.
That's why it's what you want
from your friends and your family.
You want them to pay attention to you.
It's an unbelievably valuable resource.
And so one of the things
I always tell my clients,
for example,
if they're socially anxious,
I say,
look,
pay more attention to the
person you're talking to.
If you pay,
if you really pay close attention to them,
then the thoughts that are making
you anxious will be suppressed.
And because you're paying
close attention to them,
you'll match your movements to theirs
and you'll match your conversation to
them.
And then there's no reason for you
to be socially anxious cause socially
anxious.
People will go like this
when they're talking,
you know,
they don't want look at you of course,
how the hell can you engage anyone if
you're not in a little dance with them,
you know you can't.
And a lot of it's non verbal,
it's physical and it's embodied and
without paying attention then you lose
people.
And you see this with
speakers all the time too.
There in front of audiences,
they have their paper and
they're going like this.
And usually they're talking like this too.
And you know the logical thing to do in
that case is like look at Facebook or
get the hell out of there something.
But they're not paying
attention to the audience,
and so there's no power in the,
there's no power in the
dynamic conversation at all.